what's up everybody Welcome Back wait
welcome back welcome to an episode of
director's react this is a new format
that we're exploring here on the show
because we've had the privilege of
meeting a lot of amazing people in the
industry including a lot of film
directors so please welcome David Lowry
to the couch thank you for joining us
thank you for having me it's great to be
here I feel like I'm sitting on Hallowed
Ground we are also being joined by Nick
lauron who is usually the man behind the
camera when recording the show Nick has
directed a ton of projects here at
Corridor plus some of his own so a great
guest you have on the couch as well
co-hosting with me I really admire your
work because you've been able to tell
these stories that don't really hit the
mainstream films like the Green Knight
or The Old Man and the gun starring
Robert Redford and then that's LED you
to then being able to retell stories
like Pete's Dragon or the legendary
Peter Pan which we all grew up on and
not only are these films you know big
Disney VFX heavy Blockbusters but they
also have a lot of cultural weight and
I'm really curious to pick your brain
about how you approach things like that
that I can't wait to figure it out I not
quite sure how I approach anything but
let's dig in let's do
[Music]
it are you
ready okay so the green KN this is like
a dark and gritty adaptation of this old
poem called serwin and the green KN and
being a huge history fan I just I love
the fact that you were able to make an
old Arthurian Legend reality like in
this day and age I think it was the
combination of spectacle Because by the
time I was finished with the script it
had a degree of spectacle to it and I
wanted to make something that you could
lend the imagery of say the Lord of the
Rings you could give it that sort of you
know uh spectacular heft in terms of the
visuals but that had the narrative
structure of the original poem and the
narrative Integrity that you find in
these ancient texts I wanted to try to
find a way to transfer that into
cinematic form the king speak with
you we'd initially given ourselves 3 or
4 days for this entire scene and we
massively unders scheduled it the reason
we shot last was it took the entire
length of our production to build this
set it was our one big build and we
didn't really have time to think about
how to shoot it we'd thought about it a
lot but when you walk into a set for the
first time all of a sudden ideas present
themselves to you that morning that we
walked onto the set we had a couple
hours to rehearse this entire scene and
there's this point where King Arthur
gives this speech his Christmas morning
speech to his court and I had always
imagined that he would just stand at the
front of the table and spread his arms
and give the speech but Shawn instantly
thought that he should walk around the
table he was like I I would love to
address my court face to face and a more
intimate level and it was a brilliant
idea all of a sudden that scene came to
life in a way that it wouldn't have been
had I just stuck to what I had
envisioned but it also led to lots of
other challenges such as we hadn't
planned on lighting it for that we
hadn't planned on you know needing a
study to move so we all of a sudden had
to change the way in which we were going
to shoot and it really gave us an idea
of how to shoot the rest of the scene
early on so we learned a lot while doing
that and it was one of those things that
would never have happened had I not
blocked the scene with the cast first
and then also just listen to their ideas
totally and then there were other parts
of the scene where we just didn't have
coverage of we like ran out of time to
get all the shots we wanted and I spent
so much time in post just trying to
create new shots out of old shots
finding moments like there's that shot
of Dev we just saw where he's looking
down that was something before we rolled
just him thinking before and it's was
like I need an angle specific to this
moment and I'm going to do a digital
zoom in and I'm going to add this
lightning flash okay it's just like a
gamma boost because we need a shot for
that moment and that is that him just
waiting for you to say getting the head
every good movie has one of those shots
and this sequence has so many of those I
was like I don't have a moment of where
he pauses and you just see who he's
about to to talk to we don't have a wide
shot from that angle but we do have a
wide shot when the Green Knight comes in
and so I took that shot and we froze it
and painted out the horse hoes you could
see under the door it's this one right
here nice here there's a handful of real
people but most people are seated at the
table beyond the table there's a lot of
hand painted background Talent with the
with the pointy hats the pointy hats
most of the pointy hats are painted and
then there's a couple other Lords and
Ladies and waiting back there we
invented it in post
and it works beautifully and you never
would know I forget what director said
this but you leave every production
having way more than you'll ever need
and far less than you'll actually want
and that has proven to be true time and
time
again and I've noticed you like to play
with time a lot in your films film is
about duration and as a director we get
to play with that this shot right here
was sort of like both a doorway through
which we can go as storytellers and
saying like here is where this movie
could go here's where this character
could go here's a way in which we are
inviting you to understand the way in
which this film functions this is a
combination of the most low Tech film
making imaginable and state-of-the-art
CGI we cleared out the set and we hid
behind a log as soon as the camera
leaves Dev a bunch of people spring out
of hiding run in pick him up we actually
have to lift him up I'm glad you carry
him out of frame and then we carry the
skeleton in and then my VFX supervisor
Kev kahill found this little Beetle on
location and he would run in there at
the last second and place this beetle
the beetle was real in the eye of the
skull and then run out that's a real and
it would always just like crawl out yeah
it's real and as soon as we were off the
skeleton everyone ran in moved the
skeleton away carried Dev back in and
then the only augmentation that was
required was going in and adding in the
Flora and Fauna that you see every frame
is touched by VFX but if you were to
look at the original plate it is pretty
much exactly this and the stuff that is
most notable which is Dev turning into a
skeleton was just 100% handmade I knew
this movie had the spectacle necessary
to maybe convince people to go see it
whereas if I had just made an art film
about a night on a horse journeying
across the landscape it would have been
a great movie but it probably would have
been a harder cell it is like so far
from a normal commercial movie but at
the same time it is a commercial film
and I love the fact that it opened on
1500 screens I'm really grateful for a24
for like getting behind it at that level
and saying like let's treat this like a
blockbuster even though it has a lot in
common with Art
House yes pet dragon it's super cool you
got to remake this I grew up like many
people with the original petza Dragon
just the fact that they were able to get
a cartoon character in a live action
frame to me as a kid was like magic and
then a couple years ago you got to bring
that magic magic to life for the modern
Generation by creating a photo real
dragon and you were working with WETA
pretty heavily on this how was that
experience Whata digital has done quite
a few of my movies and it was wonderful
like and we spent a lot of time you know
figuring out the best way in which to
shoot the movie so that that Dragon
would feel real and one of those was
shoot everything on location or do as
little as possible on green screen
because if we're in a real forest in the
real woods with a real tree we will
accept the Dragon in that
environment you have to treat the
character as if he is real because all
of the actors have to the actors have to
engage with him as if he is an their
scene partner but on a design level it's
a little more slippery because you know
that he is he's breaking certain laws of
physics he's breaking certain laws of
Reality by being a dragon by being a
dragon he turns invisible which makes no
sense whatsoever it was also one of the
main reasons why Elliot was never
practical I am coming from a place of
loving practical effects if I can do
something practically I will but W was
like you know the second you make it
furry you're going to have to replace
everything because the way in which fur
moves on a real creature we can do that
digitally we can create that sense of
life but if you have a big animatronic
that's covered in fur those micro clues
that tell you that this creature is
alive won't exist and you're going to
want them and we're going to have to
replace
[Music]
everything
so when you wanted to interact with the
dragon I heard stories about like a log
so we get to the climax of the film and
Pete is saying goodbye to Elliot his
best friend we know this is the heart of
the movie if this scene doesn't work the
movie doesn't work it has to function it
has to function on every level it has to
be the most emotionally moving this is
the scene that has to make everyone cry
and then of course we get to the day of
the shoot we kind of forgotten to
prepare anything we're shooting in a
real Forest that takes 2 hours to get to
every day the sun's setting we're
running out of time kids can only work a
few hours a day we're about to lose lose
Oaks who's playing Pete and we don't
have anything for him to hug and Eric
was like well we're in a forest there's
a bunch of logs over here let's uh let's
just uh wrap a log and green screen and
put it on a se you draw eyes on it or
anything for nothing nothing right here
he runs and grab that's him right now
hugging a
log and right there his hand when he
does that little clench he's just
grabbing the green screen that's wrapped
around a lot and I believe don't quote
me on this but we had to replace his
hand to get the fur interaction so if
you look around the sleeve you can see a
little shift MH but we we used mowgli's
hand from Jungle Book no way because the
digital doubles weren't quite up to par
for that level of closeup and they
already had that hand they had that hand
cuz Jungle Book was just finishing up at
that time okay and so yeah that was a a
a real moment of Awakening for me in
that sometimes when you're making a big
Studio Movie you still do things in the
most independent way
[Music]
possible what did I tell you magic so
this was your first time working with
Robert Redford this was my first time
working with Robert Redford but not the
first project we were working on
together we were we were already
developing The Old Man and the gun at
this point in time cool the kids in Pete
Dragon had no idea who he was okay yeah
and if they did it was because of
Captain America which had just come out
and so there was you know for me there's
this preciousness like again like my
voice was shaking the first day all the
kids couldn't care less and and one of
the kids at the beginning of that scene
where he's telling the story about the
Dragon one of I remember one of the kids
being like hey Rob your shoes untied and
just yeah just did not care whatsoever
no filters no filters part and it was it
was and I think he actually really
appreciated that like it was like how
nice to be working with a bunch of
actors who happen to be kids who don't
have that sense of like all the weight
that are inherently comes along with
being Robert RF
yeah excuse me I'd like to open up an
account well great what type of account
do you have in mind this kind so the old
man the gun is a true story about this
bank robber and escape artist named
Forest Tucker and it was a project that
Robert Redford had been wanting to make
for quite a long time a number of years
and after he saw my film ath thebody
Saints we had a meeting and he asked me
if I'd be interested in doing it and of
course if Robert Redford asked you do
you want to make a movie together I'm
like yes please sign me up
sure the character is a consumate Escape
Arts he broke out of San Quenton he
broke out of pretty much every prison
he'd ever been put into and I wanted to
have a sequence that illustrates that
history most of the movie is taking
place in the Twilight years of this
character's life but I wanted to
Showcase his his legacy and so we needed
a younger Robert Redford if you watch
this there's a number of ways in which
we achieved this and one of them is one
of the things that I will you know put
in my gravestone as being happiest to
get away with so that
one is a de-aging effect M subtle can
you uh guess how we did it it looks like
it's a still frame that's being tracked
onto his face in the background close is
it from a like a different movie or like
a shot from a different movie that
you've just taken we do that as well so
there's another part later on where we
pulled some footage from a movie called
The Chase in which Robert Redford
conveniently at a younger age broke out
of prison but this one was something we
shot wait is is somebody wearing a
cutout that's you printed out
100% that's why it looks 2D that's why
it looks freaking oh my gosh we went to
Kinko's dude printed out get out of here
a photo of Redford from another movie I
love it and cut it out and Scotch taped
it to someone's face I was wondering cuz
there's a little bit like that like that
head Bob the bobblehead and I was like
that could just be a 2d track where they
just kind of put it out of focus and you
know track it to the the ear something
but thank you for doing that I really
appreciate it is I I everyone including
the poor actor who wore it who was like
he was like this is so stupid he was
like I feel like a fool and he was like
um I know you do but just put the Scotch
tape face on and yeah dud what's it like
working with Robert Redford he's like a
prolific actor and director and
Storyteller what's that like having him
approach you and say yo I want you to
make this movie that I've been thinking
of for years
at first it's sort of Stupify because
you walk into the room meeting him for
the first time and he is definitely a
legend you've grown up watching his
movies you just recognize him you his
voice is so unmistakable he knows how
movies are made obviously he knows what
a director's job is he knows if a
director is doing a good job and he
knows that he is there as an actor to do
a good job as an actor I was always
wondering if he would give me notes as a
director which I would have happily
taken cuz he's made some great movies
but he never did he was there he would
always say he he was there to act and he
wanted to be there as an actor for me
and to let me direct it and for this to
be my movie and that was a great gift I
wanted this to be a movie that just made
people happy like our goal every day on
set was let's just make ourselves laugh
let's just have a good time let's let it
get goofy at times the movie gets really
goofy at sometimes let's not be precious
about it this was the one time where I
was like let's not do a lot of takes
let's kind of limit ourselves to two or
three and get out while the getting's
good and so there's a what I would call
an endearing sloppiness to this movie
that was very intentional we wanted it
to feel just a little rough around the
edges and that was one of the reasons
why we shot 16 was like we want to make
sure this feels like almost like an
indie movie that would have played at
Sundance in 1989 that was sort of the
aesthetic that we were going
for are you Peter Pan were you expecting
someone else so Peter Pan and Wendy it's
your retelling of the classic Peter Pan
story which was a super impactful part
of my child childhood it must have been
so much fun figuring a way to retell
that story for the next generation of
children my friends at the studio were
like hey would you be interested in
taking a crack at this and my first
response was no because it just felt
like a lot of pressure and then there's
also so many other great Peter Pan
movies I was going to say like how do
you how do you like say okay I think I
can take a Fresh Approach did you watch
those other versions I grew up on like
Hook was a huge deal to me like I loved
hook and I still love hook I also love
the 20
hog I think that is the truest
encapsulation of J Barry's novel that
you could possi hope for in a movie but
what could I do that is different not
even better but just different how can I
complement those other
versions I want a word for this scene we
had a rarity we had three days to shoot
about seven pages we were able to move
through the scene in sequence beat by
beat and the scene evolves as you go the
shots change we change lenses depending
on what's going on I I'm a big fan of
using lenses to communicate feeling it's
one of those subtle things audiences
don't necessarily know they're picking
up on and the shift happens over the
course of the scene like you're watching
like Captain Hook go from a very wide
lens which is very exaggerated and
somewhat and can distort people uh but
it also has an emotional Clarity to it
that I love but then you start moving to
longer lenses and the character is
clicking into the frame in a different
way so the times that we choose to go
onto long lenses in this movie are very
specific we always use those to sort of
suggest a sense of maturity and purpose
and so Captain Hook is sort of
understanding he's he's starting to
realize like right here you know we're
on a very wide lens and he's remembering
his mother for the first time he can't
even remember the word but he's like
it's coming back to him and after this
shots over we switch to longer lenses
for everything we shoot on him because
all of a sudden he's like found a sense
of composure that he didn't didn't
previously have and we do that at the
end of the movie too where Wendy all of
a sudden is because she starts off the
film as the character who doesn't want
to grow up and so we're shooting her on
28s and 32s but in the final scene she's
largely on a 65 because she's realized
her place in the world and that growing
up is in fact something that she should
do rules are meant to be broken of
course and we're not always going to
follow the rules we set out for
ourselves there are plenty of times in
this movie where a character has
achieved the maturity that would command
a 65mm lens but we're still shooting the
at 32 it's not hard and fast by any
means it's really cool how like a scene
that on paper is just a couple people
talking can have that effect on you as a
filmmaker there's lots of reasons to
make a movie like this because a story
matters because it's something that will
mean something to children who are
discovering it for the first time
because it's it means something to me
making this movie was an incredibly
emotional experience for me but then you
also get to do things like turn pirate
ships upside down and that is hard to
Discount John Michael hang on to
something everyone hang on so we we
built the pirate ship in a parking lot
of a movie theater that was closed
because of the pandemic all the water
did wind up being digital we never
actually got the boat out on water but
we did get to turn the boat almost all
the way upside down which was one of
those things I've talked about how most
of the time making these movies it feels
like you're just making a movie in the
backyard with your friends but when you
have a fullscale pirate ship that's on
what at the time was the world's biggest
Gimbal and I told Cam our special
effects coordinator like don't build
another gimbal that's bigger than this
for at least 5 years let's own this for
this chunk of time that we've got the
world's biggest gimbal what really
hurts about getting old so he's having
this fullon dialogue scene with Peter
and it was such an incredibly physical
piece of acting and I love giving actors
an emotional scenes incredibly physical
things to do yes talk about blocking
it's like how about I block my set
instead it was fantastic if the
conversation didn't happen if they
weren't talking we could have almost
played the entire scene out on that and
to be able to give of an incredibly
compelling dramatic performance while
engaged on that level on a physical
level was another reason why I wanted to
make this movie I wanted to have all the
sword fights be incredibly emotional I
wanted to have them exchanging blows
while also exchanging witty or sometimes
emotional Breer with the dialogue and
and that was you know totally one of the
one of the reasons why you get an actor
like Jude L play Captain Hook is they
can do that so we have a really really
great David on the couch and I know
there's more David's watching who are
not subscribed so David if you're
watching and not subscribed hit that
subscribe button man I'm a subscriber my
name is David I'm a subscriber this
David is setting an example that all
Davids should Aspire exactly and if you
want to see more directors react leave a
comment down below let us know what you
think of this kind of deviation from our
normal format here uh it's really cool
that you were willing to come on and
actually break the ice with us on this
so thank you so much my pleasure it's an
honor to be the the first person on this
new react series heck yeah all right
well thank you so much for joining us I
really appreciate it thank you so much
for watching Everybody we'll see you in
the next one